the thing that former fats that I will never understand
is how you can exist in a fat body
move to the world in a fat body
knowing and experiencing how difficult it is to be fat
and how cruel the world is to fat people
and instead of when you lose weight
and you are no longer feeling the effects of fatphobia
personally me
for me if I had ever lost weight and like
people start treating me better and like
I no longer was experiencing fatphobia
it would infuriate me on behalf of my old self
you know what I mean
like I cannot understand how you
in contrast are in that position
and rather than being upset at the way the world treated you
you are now contributing to the cruelty that you experienced
in this past version of your body
like that that to me is like something I just like
will never understand
and it's like
I don't know if it means that like
you hated the past version of yourself or if you still hate yourself
or if just like
you are not a good person
and you have always been waiting for this opportunity to exercise your like
dominance and like
casual cruelty on others
I don't really know what it means
but it will never
not disappoint me to see former fat people being some of the most fatphobic
I that is genuinely very disappointing to me